please rule that off if you haven't
already make this heading
we're talking about the square root of
complex numbers today now the way that
we should think about this
comes back to our understanding of
square roots in the first place okay now
this is not a trick question i promise
what is this equal to
this is five this is five and it is
unambiguously five
however i just wonder how you know
before you were introduced to
this symbol right and the idea of a
square root i wonder what
words you would use and i'm actually
going to give you a moment to pause and
turn the person next to you and suggest
this we know what the answer is
but what does it mean what is a square
root how would you articulate in words
before you had symbols to explain what
was going on this is actually really
important
for when we talked to about complex
number square roots can i give you 30
seconds to turn to the person beside you
and give me a verbal definition of what
a square root is 30 seconds go
all right i asked some of you as you're
waiting because you had your discussion
fairly rapidly which was fine with me to
jot down
what your verbal definition was and um
please don't take shortcuts around that
if you haven't written it down
write it now as i'm speaking what your
definition for this was
is anyone brave enough to share their
definition the square of a number is
what friend nice and that i said
in this context yeah one number when
multiplied by itself equals 25.
what number when multiplied by itself
gives
25 whatever's underneath the square root
or the radical sign is the name
hands up if you had a very similar
definition to rounds hands up
yep okay thank you hands down did anyone
have a radically different
radically did anyone have a really
different definition to that well that
was basically it
yeah june if you've got your aaron yeah
my friend under the bus do either of you
want to suggest
a different definition
that's how
can i can i just point out by the way
this this moment
where we're kind of thinking about
something that we feel like we know
but trying to think about how do we
articulate it this is exactly what the
work of a mathematician
looks like to be able to take something
like like we were talking before about
this guy right
this is where this whole journey began
and our willingness to
take this weird object and think about a
really careful definition for us has
just opened up a world to us
okay in the absence of more input from
here
i'm going to go with friends idea the
number that when you multiply by itself
gives you 25. i like that definition
there's just a big problem with it would
anyone like and it's a problem we all
know right what's the problem with that
definition say it again
yeah go for it sure
we are not taking into consideration the
positive and the native because we if we
take friends suggestion which was a good
one
and so it was so good that the vast
majority of you agreed
doesn't this number also fit that
definition
it does right and so in fact even though
we've never told you about this
you know how we're talking about the
principal argument right what you have
been working with what you've been
calling the square root
actually is not the square root it has
been all this time
called the principal square root we just
never told you about it because you
never knew there
was anything else right we just said hey
this thing forget about it
right forget about it because where did
we first meet the square roots of
any numbers what what topic were we when
we first needed to actually use these
things
it was think so i heard someone say
quadratic i heard trig
before that before certs years seven and
eight
think end of year seven beginning of
your eight it was say it again
pythagoras it was right angled triangles
right now all right
get this anger can you say that again
just a bit louder it couldn't have been
negative
anyway it could have been negative
because it's a length it's a length i'm
measuring something
it's going to be positive so we just
said forget about it
right however it really is
just saying one of them is more useful
to us than the other one right and it's
inconvenient to think about it so we
just forgot about it for a little while
but when we come into this world of
complex numbers
right there no longer is an argument
like this there are no longer an
argument to say oh clearly one is better
than the other which is why in your
title you wrote square roots
plural so what we're going to do is have
a look
at a number a complex number and think
about
how would we even go about arriving
at the answers to this question answer's
plural that's really important okay
now like i said i need a bit more space
um we're gonna go with
varen's definition was so good you all
agree with it i think it's a really good
start we're trying to think of a number
numbers
that when you multiply it by themselves
by
yeah by themselves you're going to
arrive there does that make sense
there's some number let's give a name
shall we
um did i call this no i didn't call
anything let
some complex number like say z
because we're so original right let's z
when you square it so that's
z squared let it equal
that that's what we want whatever that z
is it should
work right so what have i got minus 2
plus
2 root 3 i
okay and this is a really cool moment
because we have spent
the better part of a month and a bit
developing for you
multiple ways of thinking about this i
said zed but i didn't tell you
what forms ed was in and you have three
options
right would anyone like to suggest what
might be the most
natural form to start in for this
question as
pose what do you think gia
exponential form i really love if you
were thinking of exponential form right
i think there's a really good argument
to made for that let's have a think
about this we're raising something to
an exponent we've seen the whole point
of exponential form is you're naturally
talking this language
right now we are going to go there i'm
going to suggest though there's another
piece of evidence in the question that
might suggest
another form might be equally useful
any takers i mean you've only got two
other options now
here's 50 50. come on who's the betting
person right
now mod art form is another form that
when you think about it right
we introduce smart art form to think
about the angle of where things are
going right think about the starter
questions that you did today
okay you squared a number remember that
and you think about where it is based on
its modulus and its argument
however we'll point out what arc form is
basically exponential form but written
in long form right it's a longer way to
write exponential form
my suggestion for why maybe rectangular
form
might be handy here is well just have a
look at this number
this is written in rectangular form does
that make sense
real imaginary okay now fingers crossed
we will get to both today
but let's consider it in rectangular
form first so make a little subheading
which is rectangular form
if zeb is a complex number i can write
it in rectangular form like so i can say
let z equal and because i don't know
what it's real or imaginary part ah i
have to introduce some letters right
what letters would you like a plus ib
will do it for me
okay so it's a classic i can appreciate
the classics
so if that's what it is well i'm
supposed to square this thing right
so i'm going to say therefore a plus i b
all squared
equals whatever number i'm supposed to
arrive at right
negative 2 plus 2 root 3i now what we're
going to do here
is we're going to pull out an old
favorite a tool we've been using over
and over again
which is to say that right hand side
it's got a real and imaginary part
if we are really saying that these
things are equal then
the real and imaginary part from here
should be the same do you agree
so i'm going to hit pause remember
because i think you could take over from
here for a big portion of this
i want you to see how far you can get
expanding this thing out
finding the real and imaginary parts and
then making
a comparison see how far you can get you
might hit
some hurdles that's okay press on them
and see if you can make some progress
and we'll come back together
in a few minutes off you go
all right i see several of you have made
progress which is excellent
and i love that the wheels are turning
because you're like oh i get what's
going on now right
what have i done i have just expanded
here
right um just expanded everything out
i've noticed an i
squared so i have done a substitution
there for
negative one and notice that oh those
are the real parts
a squared minus b squared and then what
you get left with is the imaginary part
separated out and so i make my
comparison here they are
okay and so what you've created is a
pair of simultaneous equations we're
quite good at dealing with these right
you just have to be a little bit
cautious